what other stuff can you say about the
code base that made it difficult uh like
what are some interesting sort of quirks
broadly speaking from that compared to
just your experience with comma and
everywhere else the real thing that I
spoke to a bunch of uh
you know like like individual
contributors to Twitter and I just I had
staffed I'm like okay so like what's
wrong with this place why does this code
look like this and they explained to me
what Twitter's promotion system was
the way that you got promoted to Twitter
was you wrote a library that a lot of
people used
right
so some guy wrote an nginx replacement
for Twitter why does Twitter need an
nginx replacement what was wrong with
nginx
well you see you're not going to get
promoted if you use nginx but if you
write a replacement and lots of people
start using it as the Twitter front end
for their product then you're gonna get
promoted right so interesting because
like from an individual perspective how
do you incentivize
how do you create the kind of incentives
that will reach or lead to a great code
base what's okay what's the answer to
that
so what I do at comma and at uh
and then you know at tiny Corp is you
have to explain it to me you have to
explain to me what this code does right
and if I can sit there and come up with
a simpler way to do it you have to
rewrite it
you have to agree with me about the
simpler way um you know obviously we can
have a conversation about this it's not
a it's not dictatorial but if you're
like wow like that actually is way
simpler
like like the Simplicity is important
right but that requires people that
Overlook the code
at the highest levels to be like okay it
requires technical leadership you trust
yeah technical leadership
so managers or whatever should have to
have technical Savvy deep technical
Savvy managers should be better
programmers than the people who they
manage yeah
and that's not always obvious the
trivial to create especially large
companies managers get soft and like you
know this is just I've instilled this
culture at comma and Kama has better
programmers than me who work there but
you know again I'm like the you know the
old guy from Goodwill Hunting it's like
look man
you know
I might not be as good as you but I can
see the difference between me and you
right and yeah this is what you need
this is what you need at the top or you
don't necessarily need the manager to be
the absolute best I shouldn't say that
but like they need to be able to
recognize skill yeah they have good
intuition intuition that's Laden with
wisdom from all the battles of trying to
reduce complexity in code bases um you
know I took I took a political Approach
at comma two that I think is pretty
interesting I think Elon takes the same
political approach uh you know Google
had no politics and what ended up
happening is the absolute worst kind of
politics took over
um comma has an extreme amount of
politics and they're all mine and no
dissidence is tolerated so it's a
dictatorship yep it's an absolute
dictatorship right Elon does the same
thing now the thing about my
dictatorship is here are my values
yeah so it's transparent it's
transparent it's a transparent
dictatorship right and you can choose to
opt in or you know you get free exit
right that's the beauty of companies if
you don't like the dictatorship you quit
so you mentioned rewrite before or
refactor before features
if you were to refactor the Twitter code
base what would that look like and maybe
also comment on how difficult is it to
refactor the main thing I would do is
first of all identify the pieces and
then put tests in between the pieces
right so there's all these different
twitters of microservice architecture
um there's only different microservices
and the thing that I was working on
there look like you know George didn't
know any JavaScript he asked how to fix
search blah blah blah blah blah look man
like
the thing is like I just you know I'm
upset that the way that this whole thing
was portrayed because it wasn't like it
wasn't like taken by people like
honestly it wasn't like by it was taken
by people who started out with a bad
faith assumption yeah and yeah I mean
look I can't like and you as the program
were just being transparent out there
actually having like fun and like this
is what programmers should be about I
love that Elon gave me this opportunity
yeah like really it does and like you
know he came on my my the the day I quit
he came on my Twitter spaces afterward
and we had a conversation like I just I
respect that so much yeah and it's also
inspiring to just engineers and
programmers and just it's cool it should
be fun the people that are hating on it
is like oh man
it was fun it was fun it was stressful
but I felt like you know it was that
like a cool like point in history and
like I hope I was useful I probably kind
of wasn't but like maybe you also were
one of the people that kind of made a
strong case to refactor yeah
and that that's a really
interesting thing to raise like maybe
that is the right you know
the timing of that is really interesting
if you look at just the development of
autopilot you know going
um
from mobileye to just like more if you
look at the history of semitan was
driving in Tesla is is more and more
like you could say refactoring or or
starting from scratch redeveloping from
scratch it's refactoring all the way
down and like and the question is like
can you do that sooner
uh can you maintain product
profitability and like what's the what's
the right time to do it how do you do it
you know on any one day it's like you
don't want to pull off the Band-Aids
like it's a
like everything works it's just like
little fix here and there but maybe
starting from scratch this is the main
philosophy of tiny grad you have never
refactored enough your code can get
smaller your code can get simpler your
ideas can be more elegant but would you
consider you know say you were like
running Twitter development teams
engineering teams
would you go as far as like different
programming language just go that far I
mean the first thing that I would do is
build tests the first thing I would do
is get a CI to where people can trust to
make changes
so that people keep touching any code I
would actually say no one touches any
code the first thing we do is we test
this code base and this is Classic this
is how you approach a legacy code base
this is like what any how to approach a
legacy code base book will tell you
so and then you hope that there's
modules that can live on for a while
and then you add new ones maybe in a
different language or before we design
it new ones we replace old ones yeah
yeah meaning like replace old ones with
something simpler we look at this like
this thing that's a hundred thousand
lines and we're like well okay maybe
this didn't even make sense in 2010 but
now we can replace this with an open
source thing right yeah and you know we
look at this here here's another 50 000
lines well actually you know we can
replace this with 300 lines ago and you
know what I trust that the go actually
replaces this thing because all the
tests still pass so Step One is testing
yeah and then step two is like the
programming languages in afterthought
right you'll let a whole lot of people
compete be like Okay who wants to
rewrite a module whatever language you
want to write it in just the tests have
to pass and if you figure out how to
make the test pass but break the site
that's we got to go back to Step One
Step One is get tests that you trust in
order to make changes in the code base I
wonder how hard it is too because I'm
with you on on testing on everything I
have from tests to like asserts to Every
Which code is just covered in this
because uh it should be very easy to
make rapid changes
and no that's not gonna break everything
and that's the way to do it but I wonder
how difficult is it to
um integrate tests into a code base that
doesn't have many of them so I'll tell
you what my plan was at Twitter it's
actually similar to something we use at
comma so a comma we have this thing
called process replay and we have a
bunch of routes that will be run through
so comma is a microservice architecture
too with microservices and the driving
like we have one for the cameras one for
the sensor one for the planner uh one
for the model
and we have an API which the
microservices has talked to each other
with we use this custom thing called
serial which uses zmq Twitter uses um
Thrift
and then it uses this thing called
finagle which is a Scala uh
RPC backend but this doesn't even really
matter the thrift and finagle layer was
a great place I thought to write tests
right to start building something that
looks like process replay so Twitter had
some stuff that looked kind of like this
but it wasn't offline it was only online
so you could ship like a modified
version of it and then you could
redirect some of the traffic to your
modified version and diff those two but
it was all online but there was no like
Ci in the traditional sense I mean there
was some but like it was not full
coverage so you can't run all of Twitter
offline to test something then this was
another problem you can't run all of
Twitter
right period Twitter one person camera
Twitter runs in three data centers and
that's it yeah there's no other place
you can run Twitter which is like
George you don't understand this is
modern software development no this is
like why can't it run on my
laptop
yeah okay well I'm not saying you're
gonna download the whole database to
your laptop but I'm saying all the
middleware and the front end should run
on my laptop right that sounds really
compelling yeah
yeah but can that be achieved by a code
base that grows over the years I mean
the three data centers didn't have to be
right because they're totally different
like designs the problem is more like
like why did the code base have to grow
what new functionality has been added to
compensate for the the lines of code
that are there
one of the ways to explain is that the
incentive for software developers to
move up in the companies to add code
to add especially you know what the
incentive for politicians to move up on
the political structures to add laws
yeah same problem yeah
yeah if uh the flip side is to simplify
simplify simplify I mean you know what
this is something that I do differently
from from from Elon with comma about
self-driving cars
but you know I hear the new version is
going to come out and the new version is
not going to be better but at first and
it's going to require a ton of refactors
I say okay take as long as you need
like you convince me this architecture
is better okay we have to move to it
even if it's not going to make the
product better tomorrow the top priority
is making is getting the architecture
right so what do you think about sort of
a thing where the product is online
so how I guess would you do a refactor
if you ran engineering on Twitter would
you just do a refactor how long would it
take what would that mean for the
running of the of the actual service you
know and
I'm not the right person to run Twitter
I'm just not and that's the problem like
like I don't really know I don't really
know if that's you know a common thing
that I thought a lot while I was there
was whenever I thought something that
was different to what Elon thought
I'd have to run something in the back of
my head reminding myself
that Elon is the richest man in the
world
and in general his ideas are better than
mine now there's a few things I think I
do understand and know more about
but like in general
I'm not qualified to run Twitter as soon
as I qualified but like I don't think
I'd be that good at it I don't think I'd
be good at it I don't think I'd really
be good at running an engineering
organization at scale
I think I could lead a very good
refactor of Twitter and it would take
like six months to a year and the
results to show at the end of it would
be feature development in general takes
10x less time 10x less man hours
that's what I think I could actually do
um do I think that it's the right
decision for the business above my pay
grade
yeah but a lot of these kinds of
decisions are above everybody's pay
grade I don't want to be a manager I
don't want to do that I just like like
if you really forced me to yeah it would
make me maybe
make me upset
if I had to make those decisions
yeah but a refactor is so compelling if
this is to become something much bigger
than what Twitter was
is it feels like a refactor has to be
coming at some point George or Junior
software engineer every Junior software
engineer wants to come in and refactor
with all code
okay like that's like your opinion man
yeah it doesn't you know sometimes
they're right
well like whether they're right or not
it's definitely not for that reason
right it's definitely not a question of
engineering prowess it is a question of
maybe what the priorities are for the
company and I did get more intelligent
like feedback from people I think in
good faith like saying that
um from actually from Milo and like you
know from from Milan sort of like like
people were like well you know I stop
the world refactor might be great for
engineering but you don't even business
to run
and hey above my pay grade uh what do
you think about Elon as an engineering
leader having to experience him in the
most chaotic of spaces I would say
my respect for Amazon changed
um and I did have to think a lot more
deeply about some of the decisions he's
forced to make
about the tensions within those the
trade-offs within those decisions
I felt like a whole like
like Matrix coming at him I think that's
Andrew Tate's word for it sorry to
borrow it also bigger than engineering
it's just everything yeah like like the
war on the woke
yeah like it just it just
man and like
he doesn't have to do this you know he
doesn't have to he could go like parag
and go chill at the four seasons of Maui
you know but see one person I respect
and one person I don't
so his heart is in the right place
fighting in this case for this ideal of
the freedom of expression
but I wouldn't Define the ideal so
simply I think you can Define the ideal
no more than just saying elon's idea of
a good world
freedom of expression is
but to you it's still the downsides of
that is the monarchy
yeah I mean monarchy has problems right
but I mean would I trade right now the
Monarch or the current oligarchy which
runs America for the monarchy yeah I
would sure
for the Elon monarchy yeah you know why
because power would cost one cent a
kilowatt hour
tenth of a cent a kilowatt hour
what do you mean right now I pay about
20 cents a kilowatt hour for electricity
in San Diego that's like the same price
you paid in 1980.
what the hell
see you would see a lot of innovation
with Elon maybe it'd have maybe have
some hyperloops yeah right and I'm
willing to make that trade-off right I'm
willing to pay and this is why you know
people think that like dictators take
power through some like through some
untoward mechanism sometimes they do but
usually it's because the people want
them and the downsides of a dictatorship
I feel like we've gotten to a point now
with the oligarchy where
yeah I would provide the dictator